[Music]
first of all I really really love this
film congratulations on it I know you've
done a lot your career but how cool is
it being part Star Wars
it's triple wix man I'm so psyched to be
in this I know somebody of your caliber
and with your experience us talking off
camera about Harrison Ford
Ron Howard coming in and surprising them
I mean even you were excited about that
can I show that to you yeah the moment
it happened if we captured it I mean I
love that you're psyched about it as as
we are oh my god it's cool right you
know we don't have somebody to come in
and surprise you
that's so cool Harrison that's pretty
cool right did you get a chance to see
him while on set when he was visiting no
I I never knew he came well anyway I
never I never I guess they have some
there yet probably they all had a good
time Lucas came and said I wasn't there
for that I'm there like 900 days but I
missed the big stuff anyway that's
pretty cool
did the fact that he walked in and like
I said I know you've done a lot of big
things in your career but as your dad
status with the kid I mean has that
stock kind of gone up if they think
you're even cooler now being part of
part of this franchise my kids will ever
think I'm cool thank you
they think I'm outrageous there's like a
say stuff and they're just and I get the
I roll like I can't believe they
definitely put me in my place but mine
you know we we have a great bond so
that's fine
what are they fans of your kids that you
have now become aware of through them
well actually my my men
daughter Zoey but now she's 21 but she
was the one who got me watching friends
like I didn't know how great friends was
it's great I'm gonna seem like almost
every episode I imagine but man like
they really got how and my youngest the
11 year old Makani she loves friends as
well it's funny everywhere all big
friends Watchers in my house as well
yeah yeah it's so good it's so good yeah
uh we we love your your friendship with
with Matthew McConaughey wondering like
him being a fan of Star Wars it did he
try to hit you up for kind of spoilers
on this movie did he try and get a
little info from you breaking your NDA
no I don't remember him asking me about
that but certainly I have told him
everything
you're like what are they gonna do well
you know he's not gonna tell anybody
we love your Instagram post I'll wrap it
up of you and Helen Mirren trying to get
in on that tell on that bro man so I
made a new post in it oh yeah those
people think it's kind of cool she wants
a piece you know she wants a photo with
you I couldn't believe it she's like can
I have a picture with you guys we were
both pretty sick